welcome into this video playing let me
win let me win now don't I don't really
want to what do we get okay Scott
shrimping mmm can I do okay let's play
chess play my standard stuff yeah again
I'm so I'm always tempted by this move I
know it's not well that great but it's
my favorite move what can I do and
sometimes with you get really quick
Wednesday daiichi for what's this he's
totally ignoring this thing ok I can go
h5 in this position let's try that 23
Knight f3 just about
okay I probably have to play this one
Quincy 393 looks very fancy but it
doesn't lead to much I think I need to
be ready to take the knight on f3 hem
hey drive is a bit of a fishy look but
it's okay it's interesting at least
I'm threatening bishop age three now I
think ok so now i have to take basically
check and let's see here Bishop g4 is
kind of a bit of a shocker but he can he
can play Queen f4 and this does not bode
well for me okay probably just the
should be six this position d5 i have e
five sorry if I if I have d5 jammed it's
not so clear where my king is I were
going to go I wonder if I have g5g form
which looks really really crude but if I
go g5 he has Queen f6 this is really
problematic
you
so it just tries to trade this okay I
wonder if I just take one not take and
then g5 for Queen a form an interesting
position Queen six that doesn't help
really i wanted i want to go to e5
trying for this Queen F form Queenie
five Queen D for a black king is seven
all a bit shaky and probably not really
good
I thought I thought Queen f4 maybe or do
I a d5 he has Quincy if I ok let's go
Quinn a form but if you just takes it
this is a week f porn actually so some
some end games are kind of interesting
because my king is in the center and
very quickly able to to play a part in
this while his King is still on g1 but
on the other hand my pawn structure is
pretty dreadful ok currently i have f 3
as an idea maybe it's not that bad
really very tough tough position
I think the Queen trade is something
that I should welcome yeah that's an
interesting question taking taking but I
can take and tiki five this is something
that I should do really that's a big
center pond yeah but I can go look at
seven bishops his cheeks is really a
check just to check and I don't mind
that him that wasn't that wasn't a good
idea here's some his pawn sacrifice
their I'm really really comfortable here
so Bishop d7 getting rid of this Bishop
is a good idea
okay so how do I play this King King
King up like here and up all the way up
maybe have to be now it's okay but if he
checks me King see if I've actually
attacking the pond so he doesn't have
any yeah here FC six now it's important
yeah Luke g5 was an awkward idea but
yeah if he takes that kim taek's I'm
totally okay maybe you can take on c6
King takes root e5 yeah that's a
possibility it's not so clear how I win
from there I thought rook be eight maybe
if I go rook hey that's really passive
so nuts not let's not play passively
so I'm giving this chicken Jack getting
the King back he has this check rook a6
thats its really really unfortunate
that's not leading to anywhere this
check here
maybe this one let's got rooked if I 46
not not helping me that's not helping me
at all yeah okay is checking making c5
rogue f6 can I somehow maybe here taking
the f pawn down nope you prevented this
okay so let's go back edge so on okay so
time whining crook can do this maybe
prevent hook a five and ten they look a
four
okay so let's see if the my epon is
dangerous check check so who p.m. check
hmm yes that's true
Jeff hmm don't see a windy generally
check time winner of course but ok let's
jealous he's playing on time
unbelievable I know I'm lying on time
life is sorry you declined a draw their
I know then I'm winning on time look
against rook okay cam hmm that was kind
of strange this end game that was
surprisingly problematic maybe I'm
playing it wrong here with c6 maybe I am
hmm
yeah I'm not sure about it can i play it
differently maybe I can just do this
that's possible the ideas like this and
rook the aid maybe this is right mmm
that's better because I don't trade so
many pawns this is probably a draw yeah
i mean i can keep the pawn down but i
don't really see how I'm ever winning
here in this situation I mean I'm always
tied to the pawn so I think what i did
is essentially correct as i head this
pollution and check check chairman Jang
Cherokee yeah how do I win here i don't
i don't really see it because he has
this many checks down plan to play this
this is the computer move but i just see
how i win here i mean you can't check me
every time all the time check so yeah
okay I can do this but i don't think the
computer really excessive witness well i
think this is a drawing surely I have
nowhere to hide him computers on minus
two but I don't see ya when ya how am i
how am I countering those checks check
check check yeah here he wanted to play
on time yeah not take me there only five
okay now I want this on time like okay
what can I do if he is not taking the
draw okay well thanks for watching